هذه مسألة قضائية ،
وما أفهمه هو أنه قد
أدين وهو يقضي حاليًا
مدة سجنه
وأي حق الرجوع إلى الإجراءات القضائية
متاح بالطبع في حالة
استمرار وجود قيود زمنية ، وليس لدي
إجابة مباشرة على سؤالك
أنه قد يموت أثناء  رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني موجود هنا في حالة عدم
الإفراج عنه
، أعتقد أنه ضمن قانون العقوبات
هناك مراجعة مستمرة
للحالات الطبية لجميع النزلاء وأنه
يتم توفير الرعاية الصحية اللازمة لذلك أعتقد أنه
قد يكون هناك اعتقاد خاطئ فيما يتعلق
بوضعه الفعلي  مرة أخرى ، أعتقد أن
هناك لوائح داخل نظام العقوبات
توفر
المصالح الفضلى وصحة جميع
السجناء من قبل ، حيث قال رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني بوريس جونسون هنا
إنه يجب إطلاق سراحه ومنحه
حق الوصول إلى القنصلية ، يجب أن أضغط عليك بشأن هذا الأمر.
هذا على الأرجح لا أعتقد أن
هذا كضغط ، إنه سؤال مشروع
لا يمكنني التحدث نيابة عن
رئيس الوزراء السابق جوه.  لا أستطيع أن أتحدث
عما لدى الآخرين من حيث الإدانة ،
كل ما يمكنني قوله هو أن هذه مسألة قضائية
هنا ، فالسؤال الشخصي
قد تمت محاكمة عادلة
وتم تمثيله قانونيًا وتم إدانته من قبل
محكمة محايدة مثل أي  النظام القانوني
يجب أن يكون هناك احترام
للنظام القضائي الذي أعتقد أن
مسألة فصل السلطات
يجب أن نلتزم جميعًا بأنه
مواطن بريطاني والحكومة البريطانية
تطالب بالإفراج عنه هل من المحتمل أن يكون ذلك
جيدًا أه فهمي  مرة أخرى هو
أنه لم يتقدم
للاعتراف من قبل الحكومة المصرية
كمواطن بريطاني ،
فقد تم منحه جنسيته بينما
كان يقضي عقوبته أه
وهناك إجراء لذلك ضمن قواعدنا
وأنظمتنا وقوانيننا لأي
مصري يكتسب  الجنسية المزدوجة للوفاء بها
بحيث تعترف الحكومة
أو تصبح ثغرة لأي شخص
لارتكاب جريمة ثم يؤكد ذلك
لأنه يحمل جنسية مزدوجة